ERIC: I think college is meant
to be a time when you decide
who you are and what you're
going to do with the person
that you are.
DOMINIC: Trying to understand
truth bonds people together
in a way which very
few other things do.
JACKIE: I knew I wanted
to go to a college that
would be spiritually
edifying, a place that
would be not safe for my faith
but a safe place to grow.
CORINNE: There's always
this collaboration
of students just getting
together, supporting
one another, wanting to be
the best that we can be.
ERIC: The liberal
arts are not as
much about gathering
information as they
are learning to be the
right kind of person to land
on your feet.
HANNAH: The core
curriculum has been
essential to really see the
world as a complete picture.
JACKIE: The professors
don't see the students
as bodies in the desks.
They really see minds to
train and souls to cultivate.
DOMINIC: College is meant to be
a place where we are prepared
for the rest of our
lives, where we are formed
and we are shaped in order
to act as good human beings
with an idea of the true and
the good and the beautiful.